donc l'expérience que je vais vous
proposer de faire mentalement je pense
pour dans l'immédiat c'est de regarder
le ciel le ciel étoilé pas une très
belle soirée d'été vous pouvez constater
qu'on voit c'est magnifique étoiles moi
je depuis que je suis jeune je
m'intéresse aux aux étoiles et je les
regarde toujours avec les mêmes yeux je
crois et donc
voilà à quoi ressemble le ciel vu à
l'oeil nu c'est c'est la totalité de la
voûte céleste qui a été représentée
c'est une composition de photographies
sur la totalité de la voûte céleste et
vous voyez ces fameuses étoiles ici les
plus brillantes et pio n'a paraît-il
5000 si on regarde sur les deux
hémisphères
je n'ai jamais compté personnellement et
puis par une belle soirée d'été dans un
endroit où il n'y a pas de lumière pas
de lune vous pouvez voir ce qu'on
appelle la voie lactée une grande bande
un peu lumineuse qui traversent le ciel
et et enfin avec peut-être une carte
astronomique vous avez la possibilité
d'observer ce qu'on appelle des
nébuleuses
à ceci s'ajoutent des astres qui se
déplacent ce qu'on appelle les planètes
et puis et puis voilà ce que l'humanité
a eu à voir pendant 99 9% de son
histoire
et à partir de ça on a essayé de se
faire des représentations du monde dans
sa totalité ce qu'on appelle une
cosmologie
et dans ses représentations la
principale celle qui a eu le plus de
durer dans l'histoire au moins en europe
c'est la représentation d'aristote dans
lequel la terre était au centre de
l'univers il y avait des les astres
comme les planètes qui tournait autour
d'elle et puis y compris le soleil est
une sphère des toiles
cette vision elle va être évidemment
revisité est révolutionnée par copernic
copernic qui va s'appuyer sur les
observations désastre est proposé qui
serait plus logique que le soleil soit
au centre de l'univers
entouré des toiles dans ces étoiles
étant toujours une sphère
et ensuite galilée va commencer à faire
des observations astronomiques et se
rendre compte qu'il ya des choses très
différentes dans le ciel
quelqu'un qu'on cite - souvent c'est dur
dano bruno on le cite même presque pas
entre les deux îles et il est un
intermédiaire entre entre copernic et
galilée et j'en parle particulièrement
parce qu il a été professeur à
l'université de toulouse pendant
quelques années lui il a eu l'idée je
sais pas si les premiers mais en tous
les cas il l'affirmé fortement que les
étoiles ce sont en fait des analogues du
soleil
c'est la même chose simplement ils sont
très loin on en a qui sont très
brillante parce qu'elles sont un peu
plus près que les plus faibles qui sont
plus loin et puis il a passé l'étape
d'après de se dire mais en fait si elles
sont trop loin ses étoiles on les voit
pas mais elle existe et il imagine que
l'univers est infini rempli des toiles
jusqu'à l'infini et qu'on ne voit que
les plus brillantes les plus proches et
cette vision est bien elle va être
validé par galilée qui va avec seule sa
lunette faire ce que vous pouvez faire
vous même avec une paire de jumelles
vous regardez dans le ciel et vous
verrez que votre oeil voit beaucoup plus
des toiles que ce que vous voyez à
l'oeil nu c'est une grand changement
dans la façon de voir le monde pour à
l'époque de galilée et ils découvrent
aussi galilée quelque chose c'est que
cette fameuse voie lactée cette espèce
de luminosité un peu blanchâtre qui
traversent le ciel
c'est en fait une myriade de petites
étoiles on comprend qu'on est dans un
disque des toiles sans je passe à
travers les siècles cent milliards
d'étoilés à peu près dans notre système
des toiles au 19e siècle les astronomes
vous aurais dit voilà ça c'est l'univers
et après y'a rien c'est le vide mais il
ya quand même des choses dans le ciel
s'est en particulier c'est grande
nébuleuse
qui sont des objets sur lesquels les
astronomes ont longtemps discutée en
imaginant que peut-être puisque c'est un
ça a l'air d'être un disque ça pourrait
être un disque des toiles comme le nôtre
mais alors bon plus loin à l'extérieur
de notre propre galaxie d'autres
astronomes pensaient que c'était plutôt
des nuages de gaz à l'intérieur
philosophe emmanuel kant a pris parti au
débat il a penché pour la vision extra
galactique c'est à dire des objets
extérieurs au nôtre et vit cette
question devient très importante au au
début du 20e siècle
et est là l'astronome hubble comprend
avec le télescope le plus puissante son
époque en observant cette grande
nébuleuse d'andromède que en fait c'est
une collection de petites étoiles il
détermine la distance de cet objet et il
conclut que c'est vraiment un objet
extérieur notre système des toiles
si vous avez l'occasion de voir cet
objet par la nuit d'été pour une carte
astronomiques pour la trouver une petite
tâche tout dans le ciel vous voyez une
autre galaxie un paquet de quelques
centaines de milliards des toiles la
lumière pour venir jusqu'à vous à la
vitesse de 300 mille kilomètres par
seconde elle a mis un peu plus de deux
millions d'années
vous collectez avec votre oeil des
grains de lumière qui ont voyagé pendant
2,5 millions d'années dans l'espace à
300 mille kilomètres par seconde
je ne rate jamais ça quand je peux
et du coup ce que je vois là ce que je
veux ce que je vous montre c'est pas la
galaxie d'andromède aujourd'hui c'est la
galaxie d'andromède telle qu'elle était
il ya 2,5 millions d'années
donc nous il ya 2010 en 2.5 millions
d'années on n'était pas tout à fait sûr
le ce même aspect
la galaxie d'andromède elle alors
pratiquement pas dû changer un c'est à
peu près comme une seconde dans votre
vie sauf situations dramatiques il n'y a
pas de changement mais les astronomes
ils ont cet outil extraordinairement
puissant c'est que maintenant on va
pouvoir regarder des objets très distant
pour laquelle la lumière a mis plusieurs
milliards d'années à venir en arrière et
donc on va voir le passé de l'univers en
direct plusieurs milliards d'années en
arrière
alors ce que je vous ai montré c'est des
images telles qu'on les voit à l'oeil
augmenté grâce aux au procédé de
photographie mais l'astronomie c'est
aussi l'ouverture vers les longueurs
d'onde l'oeil ne voit qu'une petite
gamme de fréquences lumineuse et on a
des instruments qui permet de regarder
des gammes très différentes et on se
prive pas de le faire en astronomie en
particulier on observe les galaxies en
radio donc ça c'est une vieille image en
négatif mais on voit bien la structure
de la galaxie spirale et puis superposer
une carte de rayonnement radio une
fréquence particulière 21 cm qui permet
de cartographier l'hydrogène et quand on
fait de la spectroscopie de cette
lumière il d'hydrogène ou des étoiles on
peut aussi mesurer par effet doppler le
mouvement si vous en avez entendu parler
sinon vous ne croyez sur parole et donc
on voit que c'est la méthode qu'utilise
la police aussi sur la pour mesurer la
vitesse de votre voiture donc ça marche
bien
et et ses étoiles on voit qu'elles sont
en rotation autour du centre de la
galaxie ce qui est pas très étonnant
avec cette frange sociale et puis ce gaz
osciller en rotation autour de la
galaxie
tout ça n'est pas très étonnant mais par
contre quand on a un mouvement
circulaire dans un système qui est lié
par la gravitation ça nous permet de
faire un calcul très simple on va
calculer la masse de l'objet
vous avez ici de ce que les astronomes
appellent une courbe de rotation donc là
on est en train de mesurer la vitesse du
gaz qui tourne autour de la galaxie en
fonction de sa distance au rayon
et puis si vous avez fait un petit peu
de mécanique et vous n'avez pas tout
oublié sur une orbite circulaire le
carré de la vitesse cgm sur air avec un
petit coefficient qui dépend un peu de
la géométrie mais c'est pas très
important et donc sur cette image ce
qu'on voit en courbe ici c'est la courbe
qu'on aurait compte tenu de la quantité
de gaz et des toiles qu'on voit dans cet
objet
est donc ce que vous voyez aussi c'est
que la vitesse de rotation reste très
élevé sur la partie extérieure on va
dire trois fois plus grande donc comme
sa balle comme le carré ça veut dire que
la masse et plus grande d'un facteur
presque 10
dans cette galaxie à dix fois plus de
masse que ce qu'on a été capable de voir
soûlard montre une dernière fois dans
cette région de l'espace est à peu près
10 fois plus de masques ce qu'on a sur
cette carte on a observé en infrarouge
en ultraviolet en rayons x en rayons
gamma ou tout ce que vous voulez on n'a
jamais rien vu d'autres et donc ce
problème là on appelle ça la matière
noire c'est un mauvais termes l'air qui
entre vous et moi je le vois pas ça
viendrait personnes d'appeler ça de la
matière non c'est la matière
transparente invisible
on
n'en voit que les conséquences par
l'action de la gravité donc ici vous
avez par exemple un centre de galaxies
un amas de galaxies à plusieurs dizaines
de galaxies qui sont rassemblés un
endroit et la lumière quand elle se
propage va être déviée par la masse
totale de ce système or c'est une
observation qui a été fait la première
fois par une équipe toulousaine au
siècle dernier
mise en avant et vous voyez lit les
objets qui sont derrière sont déformés
par la déviation des rayons lumineux
comme ça on peut à nouveau
visualiser un petit peu la distribution
de cette matière noire qui seraient
sinon invisible
on a fait le bilan de toute cette
matière noire elle représente à peu près
30% d'une densité que des cités de
référence qu'on appelle la densité
critique
mais ça c'est quelque chose qui est tout
à fait incroyable alors pourquoi c'est
incroyable parce qu'en fait on sait
calculer la quantité d'atomes qui doit y
avoir dans l'univers primordial connaît
les réactions qui se passe entre les
atomes ce qu'on appelle la
nucléosynthèse primordiale et ça nous
dit qu'il doit y avoir à peu près 5% de
la densité critique de l'univers sous
forme d'atomes that home c'est ce qui
nous constitue ce qui constitue vous et
moi l'air la table tout ce qui est dans
cette pièce
en fait tout ce que vous connaissez
tous que les physiciens connaissent dans
la nature de stable et fed atone et donc
on est en train de dire
70 % de ce qui constitue la matière dans
l'univers s'est fait de quelque chose
qui n'est pas des atomes appelle ça la
matière non baryonique c'est un mot
savant pour dit on sait pas ce que c'est
mais on sait que c'est pas des atomes ou
est-ce qu'on voit des choses qui sont
pas des atomes dans les accélérateurs de
particules ont créé des particules par
exemple neutrinos qui n'est pas dans la
famille des atomes qui pourrait
contribuer à la densité de l'univers en
mai on connaît les caractéristiques
d'une un trinôme et c'est pas il n'est
pas capable d'expliquer ce qu'on voit
mais du coup on pense que c'est une
nouvelle particule ou peut-être quelque
chose d'autre que l'on on n'a pas encore
pensé
je vais tuer vous réservez une deuxième
surprise je vais vous parler maintenant
de l'énergie noire
donc comment la trouvez en cherche des
supernovas des supernovas ce sont des
étoiles qui explosent à la fin de leur
vie ça devient très très très brillant
autant que les 100 milliards de dhs
étoiles de notre galaxie
ça dure évidemment pas très longtemps
quelques quelques jours et donc ça se
produit une fois par siècle et par par
galaxie donc évidemment on va pas
observé une galaxie à la fois parce que
sinon ça va être un peu long donc on
observa une grande quantité de galaxies
en même temps et on revient
régulièrement à faire des mêmes images
enfin des images de la même région du
ciel est ici vous avez un faisceau un
petit carré qui a été agrandi pour vous
montrer quatre objets ce sont quatre
galaxies tous les petits points que vous
voyez sur cet écran à part ceux qui ont
une petite croix ce sont des galaxies
chacun 10 à 100 milliards des toiles on
observe des très grandes régions du ciel
comme ça et on détecte de temps en temps
qu'il se passe quelque chose ce qui se
passe ici là vous avez une galaxie qui a
changé de luminosité
normalement ça ne peut pas arriver donc
c'est en fait une étoile qui a changé de
luminosité de façon dramatique ça c'est
des images qui sont prises depuis le sol
l'eau qu'elles sont un peu floues mais
si on va dans l'espace avec un télescope
spatial comme le télescope hubble eh
bien on voit très bien les images très
piqué donc ici vous avez vous
reconnaissez bien la forme d'une galaxie
non plus d'une de deux tâches flou ici
ce qui ressemblait à une cacahuète c'est
en fait de galaxies et c'est dans une d2
qui a eu la petite étoile cette
supernova
on la suit et comme on connaît très bien
c'est super nova on sait mesurer sa 10 à
luminosité totale et donc sa distance et
donc on va me faire exactement ce que
faisaient ils veulent mesurer des
vitesses et des distances mais d'objets
qui sont non plus aujourd'hui mais
plusieurs milliards d'années dans le
passé et comme ça on va reconstituer
l'expansion de l'univers au cours du
temps on sait que l'univers est en
expansion au delà montrer et on va
maintenant comment regarder objet de
plus en plus lointain on va voir si
cette expansion augmentent au cours du
temps ou ralentie au cours du temps
les équations qui gouvernent l'expansion
c'est exactement les équations qui
gouverne le mouvement d'une pièce en
fait c'est la gravité dont la galaxie
est en train de s'éloigner de moi parce
qu'elle a une vitesse d'éloignement et
elle est soumis à la gravité des
galaxies qui m'entourent donc si la
galaxie ne va pas assez vite elle
retombe si la galaxie va très vite elle
à partir à l'infini pour l'éternité
mais en fait la vitesse on la connaît on
la mesure par l'effet doppler ce qu'on
connaît pas c'est la densité de
l'univers
donc c'est la densité de l'univers qui
va déterminer si l'expansion se fait
éternellement pas et on s'attendait
évidemment à ce que ce mouvement soit
toujours ralenti
et comme souvent science quand on attend
quelque chose des fois on trouve le
contraire
obligé de le croire sur parole ça c'est
le diagramme de hubble qui nous montrent
la distance des objets en fonction de
leur vitesse et si on était dans un
univers ralenti la courbe devrait
s'incliner vers le bas et le fait
qu'elle s'incline vers le haut sa montre
que l'expansion se fait de plus en plus
vite ça veut dire que mes galaxie elles
subissent non pas une force attractive
qui a ralenti leur vitesse d'éloignement
mais au contraire une force répulsive
qui les fait s'éloigner de plus en plus
vite
c'est quelque chose qui est maintenant
complètement établies et plus du tout
contester l'expansion de l'univers est
accélérée ça veut dire la gravitation la
force de gravitation galilée newton
einstein
on a tous ratés que on n'avait pas le
bon signe à l'échelle de l'univers
mais ça maintenant alors c'était
suffisamment important pour que les le
comité nobel décident d'attribuer le
prix nobel de physique ce qu'ils ont
découvert cette accélération de
l'expansion
lessard est aujourd'hui un des grands
mystères de la physique moderne et de la
cosmologie on est confronté grâce aux
données astronomiques à deux problèmes
majeurs qui sont vraiment des points
bloquants dans notre compréhension du
monde qu'est ce que c'est que cette
matière noire qui est très présente qui
est pas faite d'atomes est encore pire
qu'est ce que c'est que cette énergie
noire qui produit une gravitation
répulsive
voilà on a un projet de satellite
européen qui s'appelle clide qui va
cartographier des galaxies lointaines
sur un volume le plus grand possible qui
pourra faire pour qu'on comprenne en
mieux en détail cette matière noire et
cette énergie noire
voilà je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]